[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
okay unbelievable so far
hundreds of challengers but no winners
we've never made a mistake no the show
is flawless flawless like a gem a gem
yeah night after night well tonight a
fan with the screen name
bhanks23
says he thinks he has caught a mistake
he says it happened when i showed a
photo from the white house
correspondents dinner on the air
hey conan
on your may first show
i caught you making a very basic common
grammatical error
when you held up a photo of yourself
with matthew perry you said
here's matthew perry and
i that is terrible grammar conan
the word i is a subjective pronoun
but in that sentence you were referring
to yourself in the objective case
therefore you should have used the
objective pronoun of me
conan
i would expect you to be able to put a
basic sentence together by now
[Music]
yeah you will boo all you want but this
is just sad be hank's 23 you are dead
wrong this guy thinks he's got me yeah
well listen to this i didn't say matthew
perry and i i said matthew perry and die
d i the name
die
yeah and if you took off your goofy
comedy glasses for a second you might
have noticed who was actually in the
photo i was showing on the air allen
could you please roll the clip from the
show
here's matthew perry and i die of course
referring to the senior senator from
california dianne feinstein
here's matthew perry and i died this
time referring to abc news anchor diane
sawyer
here's matthew perry and i diana ross
what a legend here's matthew perry and
die dilophosaurus the early jurassic
predator here's matthew perry and die
diverticulitis the painful disease of
the bowel and finally here's matthew
perry and die die being short for
director of
[Applause]
he grammardork.com listen
[Music]
so anyway i think our record our record
remains right and i just want to correct
that one right now
i'm not gonna go counting you said
record
that one doesn't count because i've been
drinking
so the challenge still stands if you
think you've spotted an era on our show
reported at teamcoco.com
haha i found an error we will sort it
out right here on the air let's see if
you've got what it takes to make chump
meat out of the maestro we'll take a
break